[Music]
foreign
briefing it's Friday May 26th I'm Julie
Chang for the Wall Street Journal
filling in for Zoe Thomas
parents and teachers have been worried
about the way generative artificial
intelligence tools like Chachi PT could
impact learning Hadi partovy is the
founder and CEO of code.org a non-profit
focusing on Computer Science Education
he sat down with the Wall Street
journals editor for Europe Middle East
and Africa Thorold Barker at this year's
future of everything festival and they
talked about how schools will need to
adapt to students growing use of AI the
impact AI will have on inequality and
more here are highlights from their
conversation
what should schools be doing let's start
short term I mean what should their
short-term response to this be
so the most common short-term response
has been Banning the use of things like
chat GPT which I'm not sure is terrible
as a short-term response first of all
because many of these AI tools aren't
licensed for use by students who are
under 18 but also because schools are
currently assigning homework that could
just be done in a second by by an AI so
I'm not against bands as a very
short-term tool but what schools really
need to be thinking about is how to
change not only how we teach but even
what we teach what we expect students to
learn so that instead of teaching
memorization and wrote practice we teach
creativity problem solving critical
thinking and the use of technology for
for doing the things that right now
students are doing by pen and paper and
I honestly think education is going to
need to change not only once but
education is going to need to start
becoming a more adaptive system you know
we we invented the the global education
system for the technology of centuries
ago with the printing press us and books
as the main technology for information
gathering and our education system is
designed around reading everything you
can and then getting all the knowledge
inside your head and now we have
information at your fingertips and AI
that can synthesize even new thoughts
and bring things together we need to
rethink how we teach in a world where
lifelong learning is how we work things
not just 16 years of of learning so what
are you most excited about I mean if you
could point to something that you hope
is changed in 10 years time in schools
what what are the the one or two things
you'd really love to see
I mean it's very hard to to think 10 to
10 or more years time but it's worth
noting that a student starting
kindergarten today is going to be
graduating in the late 20s 30s and so
our school system needs to think about
what what are things going to look like
then but I believe in the long run
education will be much more personalized
and AI is going to be much more of a
tutor that you learn from and your
teacher is going to be much more of a
coach and the personalization of
learning also means much more adaptation
of what a student's passions are rather
than everybody needs to memorize the
same information from all these subjects
there's a smaller level of stuff that
everybody's going to need to know in
their heads with access to a lot more
depth if they use technology and AI for
learning
is this an opportunity to reduce
inequality is it going to increase
inequality of Education what's what's
going to happen with this it's a little
bit of both access to computers and the
internet
is not equal and so for folks who don't
have that kind of access this will widen
those gaps but for folks who do have
digital access it's very much of an
equalizer because the more of a role AI
plays as a teacher as a tutor everybody
will have the same high quality tutor
right now the quality of teaching varies
very much from classroom to classroom
from country to country but the quality
of the technology that they use is much
more equal and are you seeing I mean if
you look at you know take New York City
you talked about the fact that
um
you know you're not meant to use it
under 18 and and public schools have
said you can't use it for for reasons of
gaming tests Etc
um has the same happened in the private
system and are you seeing a very
different approach
um from those two systems right now it's
different and that's part of the irony
in New York City in the public school
system these AI tools are banned at
Dalton the private school you know
there's courses that teach how to do
prompt engineering using Ai and prompt
engineering just learning how to use
these AI tools that most creatively is
leads to a six-figure salary but it's
being taught in the private school not
the public school but that's a
short-term situation I think both should
be arriving at the same place in the
long run
so so over time so so short term
it widens that Gap longer term
you hope it'll
um
I think it's going to be a great
equalizer
um what are the biggest dangers of this
coming into the curriculum that you see
so I mean you know obviously you're
trying to get it learned about so people
understand how AI works and I assume the
shortcomings and and everything else
around it and also they use it for for
teaching but but what is the danger here
a lot of people there's many risks and
part of the reason schools have been
Banning this the main reason they've
been Banning it is they just it does all
the homework for you so they're not sure
what the meaning of their their the way
the school system works is going to be
if it does that but there are other
risks there's certainly the risk of
misinformation because the way
generative AI works it doesn't know
everything it's kind of a really well
optimized guessing machine it does its
really good best guess at what you look
for but that best guess could be
completely false so misinformation is
one issue bias is another issue because
the data that AI has trained on is is
human information and human learning and
if that human created learning has
biased the AI will perpetuate that bias
student privacy and data privacy is
another risk but what I'd say is the
greatest risk of all is not changing not
evolving education and just assuming
that the education system from the 1800s
is going to be equally relevant in the
2030s and that's it for Tech news
briefing this week before we go a quick
programming note we'll be off on Monday
for Memorial Day but we will be back in
your feed on Tuesday
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
our executive producer is Chris zinsley
and I'm Julie Chang filling in for our
host Zoe Thomas thanks for listening and
have a great weekend
[Music]